In 1999, he was dispatched from Renault to the near bankrupt Nissan.
Nissan is one of Japan's top 3 automakers alongside Toyota and Honda...
...and Ghosn restored it to profitability in a year by closing factories...
...and breaking up close-knit supplier networks to save costs.
Under Ghosn, Nissan introduced the all-electric Leaf.
It says the Leaf is the world's best-selling electric vehicle...
...but sales have fallen well below initial goal.
More recently, Nissan's Note model,...
...which includes a hybrid version with an electric motor,...
...has supplanted Toyota's Prius as Japan's best-selling model.
The Renault-Nissan Alliance plans to sell 10 models...
...with autonomous driving technology by 2020.
And Ghosn is expected to stay active in charting the company's path.